hasn't been seen since november the
second when the tennis star published
shocking allegations about sexual
assault at the highest levels of the
chinese communist party
high-profile players like naomi osaka
and novak djokovic had called for more
information
and then in the middle of the night in
beijing chinese state media cgtn said it
had the scoop an email purportedly
written by pong to the head of the
women's tennis association it read the
news in that release including the
allegation of sexual assault is not true
i'm not missing nor am i unsafe i've
just been resting at home and everything
is fine thank you again for caring about
me
cgtn doesn't have much of a track record
for breaking big news
it does have a track record for airing
forced confessions for which it was
fined by ofcom the british media
regulator
the email didn't convince the head of
the wta it's a great concern to us that
we have not been able to reach her
we've used every option that we know of
today and followed up on every lead
that's been given to us
but to date we haven't been able to
reach her we definitely want to speak to
her directly and make sure that she's
okay
she knows that we're here to support her
and if there's anything that we can do
to help her personally as well as her
family
celebrities go missing in china with
warring regularity actress fan being
being disappeared for months with no
information eventually reappearing to
apologize for tax fraud
but pong shui's post went way beyond
that she said she had been forced into
sex by zhang gaoli who served as china's
vice premier for five years before
retiring it stunned social media
resonating with a metoo movement
authorities have tried to repress
the post was quickly censored along with
other search terms even including the
word tennis
here's how that censorship works in
action this is a screenshot of
punctualized initial post where she says
she was sexually assaulted now if i try
and send this to my colleague's phone
here on my screen it says it's got
through but he hasn't received anything
it simply hasn't been allowed to be
delivered there's a darkly ironic term
for this sort of censorship here they
call it being harmonized
beijing will host the winter olympics in
february at the same time it has
apparently disappeared a three times
chinese olympian
the hashtag being used online is a
simple question one that people will
only ask louder where is punggshui
tom cheshire sky news beijing